el supuesto parón estratégico anunciado
por las fuerzas rusas días atrás no ha
sido sentido por la población de la
región del donbass donde está el
principal frente de batalla en este
momento en la provincia de don es que
una población conocida como chasing ya
hay al menos 30 personas fallecidas que
estuvieron bajo los escombros de una
edificación atacada este fin de semana
pero las fuerzas de rescate siguen
buscando más cadáveres en la ciudad de
jarc y también hubo otro ataque en un
momento en el que presidente ucraniano
wladimir selenski habló por teléfono con
su contraparte turca el presidente de
recep tayyip erdogán para hablar como
poder desminar esos puertos del mar de
grupo de abrir esas rutas para sacar el
grano que está en este país no solamente
el que se haya acumulado en los silos y
no ha podido salir sino que se que se
está empezando a recoger unas cosechas
que cada vez presentan más preocupación
no solamente porque muchos de los campos
están minados sino que otros están
siendo quemados